le choc a été brutal
le séisme économique causée par la
pandémie continue de se faire sentir
c'est le moment le plus important de la
vie de notre europe depuis la création
de l'euro déjà les dirigeants du monde
face à l'ambitieux plan de relance un
conducteur paquet enso qui s'acquittent
des sommes colossales seront dépensés
pour retrouver le chemin de la
prospérité
un effort sans précédent depuis la
deuxième guerre mondiale et il n'y a pas
une minute à peine nos alliés du g7
saisissent tous ce moment pour agir et
on doit la saisir
aussi c'est vraiment compétition est-ce
qu'on va gaspiller le moment en anglais
on dit en europe l'allemagne a ouvert la
voie
un plan de relance de 130 milliards
d'euros une somme considérable pour un
pays qui a l'habitude de la rigueur
budgétaire et notre ministre finances
elle a appelé le grand canon et bisous
cas pour stimuler le pouvoir d'achat des
ménages
l'allemagne a réduit de 3% sa taxe de
vente une mesure en vigueur jusqu'à la
fin de l'année
mais à long terme le pays a choisi son
chemin on veut se préparer pour le futur
on veut être créée vers le tiers des
dépenses vise à réduire les émissions
allemandes
7 milliards d'euros pour développer une
filière de l'hydrogène ou le pétrole du
futur comme l'appelle le gouvernement
allemand pour faire rouler ses voitures
et ses industries
subvention à l'achat d'un véhicule
électrique les plus généreuses de tout
le continent
l'inaction climatique serait encore plus
coûteux selon et je crois qu'on risque
de manquer une occasion de transformer
nos économies pour un futur plus
soutenable les pays européens ont une
cible commune d'être carboneutre en 2050
la france va dans la même direction et
propose un plan de 100 milliards d'euros
sur trois ans investissements dans le
transport en commun et rénovation
énergétique des bâtiments par exemple
nous devons dépenser vite et nous devons
dépenser bien pour inciter les
entreprises à produire en france des
allègements fiscaux et de l'argent dans
les secteurs de pointe et l'ambition
n'est pas une affaire européenne qui
évoquera jean-claude longue enquête la
corée du sud vient de dévoiler son new
deal version 21e siècle inspiré du plan
du président roosevelt pendant la grande
dépression 125 milliards canadiens d'ici
objectif créer près de deux millions
d'emplois l'un des piliers est un grand
chantier numérique et profite d'une
crise pour ses traits un pieu des
investissements massifs pour accélérer
d'utilisation des données de
l'intelligence artificielle et de la
technologie 5g dans les industries sud
coréenne l'objectif de former 100 mille
personnes en intelligence artificielle
le plan prévoit aussi de développer
l'éducation et la médecine en ligne le
gouvernement du canada un retard d
autres pays développés dans la mise en
place de programmes l'économie
intelligence artificielle technologies
propres
le canada doit placer sa mise sans quoi
il risque de perdre son avance dans des
secteurs clés le secteur de
l'aéronautique
c'est un secteur très fort depuis très
longtemps au canada depuis presque une
centaine d'années où il ya un risque
très important de perdre des
investissements
combien doit investir le canada pour
être compétitif on se comparant aux
autres
cet expert riva d'une prédiction on peut
peut-être considérer un plan de 100
milliards $ le canada le canada n'est
pas parmi les premiers a détaillé son
clan et ce ministre ne semble pas s'en
inquiéter que notre plan soit non ces
trois mois ou quatre mois plus tard que
celui de la france ou d'allemagne
je tiendrai pas chômé là dessus le
gouvernement trudeau est à la planche à
dessin son discours du trône servira de
boussole pour orienter l'économie
canadienne emplois verts climat filet
social renforcé ottawa a déjà annoncé
ses couleurs des volets verts et volets
qui tape dévoilait puis juste en pleine
gestion des risques sanitaires
ottawa doit au même moment faire des
choix déterminant pour son avenir
économique
le canada n'a pas droit à l'erreur parce
que ses alliés sont bien déterminés à
saisir tout le potentiel de la crise